including those represented here really
I think do represent the top of the
field here I no longer I can we can be
described them as emerging architects I
think we can happily say that they have
fully emerged so it's your job now to
evaluate the consequences of that that
emergence so and in a sense that's
that's really you know that's really
what what brings us together here an
effort to with Enrique to try to to to
stage a discussion a debate maybe even
an argument in the spirit of the
arguments series that the ad program has
been running to tease out some of the
undercurrents if you'll pardon the usage
of not so much the tea i mean there will
be of course a lot of discussion about
the particular do those are the projects
but but the stakes of the the work and
and particularly how it articulates
itself in the broader field so so
towards that end I before introducing
our panelists that the setup will be
this I will introduce everybody right
now so we can and we have three of the
five teams represented here we've
limited this to current Columbia faculty
partly also i should say as a way to to
you know look in the mirror a little bit
and get have some sense and maybe
introduce you to some of the work and
discussions that that you're likely to
encounter here columbia so so so i will
introduce our speakers and
who each will present about 10 minutes
basically will present there are
projects to you and after which Enrique
and I will pose to each of us we will
pose questions that we've actually
discussed a little bit in advance so we
we've prepared this in order to try to
to to steer the discussion in a specific
direction we'll see if it complies and
so I'll give it just also to our
colleagues a little bit of a advanced
hint as the kinds of questions that we
had in mind for my part I was interested
in given the nature of this this project
you know this is the hypothetical
project maybe I should give a little bit
of background so that way these guys
don't have to give you every detail but
that there's very very unusual for moma
I mean I must say although it is very
much in the in a tradition and older
tradition of workshop type exhibitions
that MoMA has hosted there were a number
of such exhibitions in the 60s and early
70s and so the the idea was I'll speak
on behalf of my colleague Mary Bergdahl
who was the curator of the exhibition
that that there was an issue the issue
of the rise rise of the water level in
New York Harbor there was a site the
harbor itself and they were a series of
of architects who threw a fairly
elaborate process we're invited to
address that issue on that site really
on five different sites around the
harbor what's interesting to me about
about that setup and and what I had you
know would like to ask in more detail
later is is is that this the nature of
that narrative presupposes something
like a long-term future it's almost a
kind of science fiction exercise and and
and that was certainly the first
impression I had been entering the
exhibition that basically you're
entering a science fiction show but it's
the science part and the fiction part
are in a sort of complicated than maybe
interesting dialogue it's science
fiction in the sense that it
extrapolates out of present conditions a
future a long-term future we're talking
about these projects are basically you
know 50 80 years you know addressing
conditions that are expected 50 or 80
years down the road and the scientists
can't exactly tell you what really to
expect and obviously this reflects
conditions in the present the state of
the environment so not to say a
long-term historical trends so so my
question essentially has to do with
relationships between past present and
future and and you know what means to
think and operate in that sort of those
temporalities and and just to to try to
translate a little bit and summarize
what I think Enrique is going to ask
about will have to do with in fact each
projects argument the claims that it
makes as as an architectural and urban
istic proposition and specifically
regarding the city in a sense the city's
the type of the kind of city that it
imagines that the sort of propositions
visiter the city I think maybe we could
understand this a little bit in
relationship to the two that I think
really fantastic
strategy of inducing arguments out of
people that Enrique has become very
adept at and and I you know know that
you've been doing all summer so so I
think you can expect some some prodding
from Enrique on that on that note and
probably some others as well so so I
think that's probably enough to
introduce the the the format and the
frame and and so I will just now three
in a row introduce our speakers each of
them of them then present their work and
then we'll pick up the discussion be
prepared though yourselves with
questions as you look and listen because
that's really the spirit of this that
you know the idea really is to try that
22 based on the work to to have a
hopefully lively and high stakes
discussion about about its its claims
and its possibilities so to begin with
we will have Eric bungay who in
partnership with Mimi Guang are the
principles of from n architects and
architects was founded in new you're
here in New York City by in 1999 the
variety in their body of work
demonstrates the firm's interest in the
varian variability itself aiming so you
can hear some of them just reading our
sort of the bios that we've culled from
the internet so you can try to
anticipate a little bit variability
itself aiming for maximum effect with it
within an economy of conceptual material
means and a positive impact on the
environment the firm's award winning
projects include the bamboo canopy for
moma ps1 of 2004 the ephemeral pavilion
wind shape and lacoste france in 2006
and the seven-story switch building in
Manhattan 2004 2007 and in fact an
architect's is this is maybe related
phenomenon it's quite interesting about
architectural culture here in New York
an architect's is one of 24 firms
retained by New York City's ddc for the
design excellence program and one of
eight pre-qualified architecture firms
for the New York
the parts department in addition to
working with these city agencies they're
currently working with the city of Paris
on a digital haul for public square in
captain McClay in Paris following Eric
will be marked or Maki all of whom i
should say again teach in different
dimensions of our studio and other
curricula here so you're likely to
encounter these figures elsewhere too
but mark is going to represent his firm
the partnership of Louis Samaki Lewis
with his partners David Lewis and Paul
Lewis or LTL architects which is a
design intensive architecture firm
founded in nineteen ninety seven by
these three figures ltl engages a
diverse range of works from large-scale
academic and cultural buildings to
interiors and speculative research
projects they realize inventive
solutions that turn the very constraints
of each project into the design project
trajectory exploring opportunistic
overlaps between space program form
budget and materials LTL architects is
the recipient of the 2007 National
Design Award for interior design from
the cooper-hewitt national design museum
and was selected as one of six American
architectural firms featured in the US
pavilion at the 2004 Venice Biennale
their work is in the permanent
collection of the san francisco museum
of modern art and the hinds
architectural center at the carnegie
museum of art in 2009 indeed again ltl
architects were selected by the by New
York City Department of design and
construction that's ddc to participate
in the design and construction
excellence program they are currently
complete completing work on art house at
the jones center in austin texas and the
administrative center for the claremont
University Consortium in California and
finally k orff will represent her firm
scape scape as a design-driven a
landscape architecture and urban design
studio it shares a commitment to
innovative design and construction of
the urban landscape its goal is to
create an organized dialogue about the
built environment to refine the
definition of the public sector to
include natural processes in wildlife
habitat and to cultivate an ethos of
civic participation
skate is currently working on the
remediation of a 200-acre city worth 200
acre brownfield site in Greenville South
Carolina the first in a series of nature
center Nature Center projects the studio
currently has five projects on the board
with again the New York City Department
of design and construction that maybe
this is a subtext BBC at large projects
underway in both Battery Park City and
along the East River so again you can
look forward too much more in this city
in us we're from from these these firms
and we're here today to discuss to
discuss their proposals for for this
city so I with that i'll invite eric to
take over and woke them all thank you
can we have the first slide please do I
need to do that right now yeah there's
okay all right good afternoon thank you
I know thank you come again just with
this right yeah in the spirit of you
know disclosing arguments I thought I'd
start with a few images of our proposal
that we submitted back in October for
consideration to participate in this
which also allows me to introduce the
team my partner mimi hong myself Eric
boom gay and our four team members sunk
tekli centric to sin no Olivia marry
Lewbert on George happened joined us as
well and two important collaborators our
of New York and matured hakuna and the
second page of well the third page of
our submission was a kind of spoof of a
meeting agenda that we you know might
have worried to be selected and from
this I want to disclose a few of the
arguments for our issues that we thought
would be important and the stayed with
us five in fact the first one was in
fact the issue of vision and future
itself and we included a quote from the
week on and i quote i was asked by
general electric company to help them
design a spacecraft one person put an
illustration on the table and said Mr
Khan we want to show you what a
spacecraft will look like 50 years from
now I said immediately it will not look
like that and they move closer to the
table and they said
you know as that it was simple if you
know what a thing look like 50 years
from now you can do it now but you don't
know because the way I think will be 50
years from now is what it will be but
the issue in bringing this up is to look
at the problematic relationship between
prescribing for the future relationship
to the issue of agency in in a large
project like that in urban design so we
thought the interesting issues would be
problem definition relationship to the
existing city and issues of
representation of future conditions the
the second issue was issue of an issue
of sight which is problematic in itself
in a large project but problematic
especially in an aqueous terrain where
fluid boundaries you know no longer
subject to planimetric or instrumental
mappings of upper ground you know make
it very difficult to determine whether
slightest but also the whole issue of
sight and larger context of the future
and our interventions as architects the
third is the issue of density if we
extrapolate projections for population
growth for every inch of rising sea
level which is not as slow as maybe Ryan
will mention it well you never know but
it could be a three-eighths of an inch
of a year we could have 200,000 new
immigrants to the city and so you know
we think that environmental issues
should not be disassociated from social
issues and real issues forth soft
infrastructure one of the premises
posited by gene or dances team for the
show and is relationship too hard
infrastructure and whether there could
be a gradient between those that allows
a better integrate with the city and
finally issues of representation which
will get back to at the end so starting
with an image this is the new york
harbor manhattan at the very top sandy
bay and shown here is what engineers
would recommend on one of three sides
for a storm surge barrier at Sandy Hook
the point of the slide is not only to
show that you know hard infrastructure
conditions or solutions are as we know
now from Katrina and others situations
you know problematic in that they can
fail they're not resilient and
multi-layered but also the notion of
sight is that as we know from the Gulf
that an action in one place really you
know affects other areas so for us the
first decision we made was that
we don't think of it as a site at all
rather's a window onto a possible future
this is our set of focus sunset park and
Bay Ridge in Brooklyn verrazano-narrows
in Staten Island so inherently a very
varied set of conditions both physical
and social and here you see the 20-foot
inundation line of a category three
storm so bottom right Bay Ridge is
pretty steep it's not going to be
affected by that that much sense a park
quite significantly and then on the last
Staten Island the social conditions are
also interesting the residential
communities there you know there's
pressure for them to grow as well as
jobs to be maintained so our strategies
are threefold basically and you can
numerate them and see if we succeeded
but one is to bring the water into the
land make the city's subsidy more
resilient to water but also to embrace
opportunities of living out on the water
and I'll shying away from it and we
think that any sort of buffer of park or
anything else is almost the same as a
hard infrastructural condition in that
it separates the city from the water the
second is a kind of acupuncture urbanism
idea to borrow from Jaime Jaime Lerner
an idea of disbursing infrastructure so
that it will instigate habitat biddulph
am sponsored communities and create a
resilient City and the third has to do
the problems I raised in the beginning
that rather than seeing this as a design
problem which for such a large project
with many actors or the top down
thinking bottom of thinking you know
municipal and other city agency and
state initiatives as well as private
initiatives it's impossible to think of
it as design so we conceived of the
whole project as a fictional zoning
resolution and shows a sort of title
there's a spoof of 60s visionary
projects new aqueous it II hardly knew
because we're dispersing a lot of
infrastructure so I'm going to show off
short video in a second that gets into
detailed about three very washed out
slides aqueous neighborhoods public
peers and barriers and Islands
that is full screen okay the public
waterfronts we're extending the city to
the water and bringing the water to the
city with floating boardwalks and pure
parks that capture sediment and provide
habitat for wildlife on the down current
side way of deflecting peers with
service dogs for a new tram and bio gas
powered very sorry that's the up ground
side on the down current side piers will
capture sediment and smells of habitat
our objective ultimately to create new
dynamically changing public spaces that
include mobile floating amenities on
mobile barges and connections between
land and water transport intertwined
within this political of is a public
waterfront and below the 20-foot
inundation line we imagine new
neighborhoods rasili to sea level rise
normally we built from a shared street
up our new actress building technology
inverts that by building down from a
shared roof structure the more risk
you're willing to take the closer to the
water you hang your house instead of an
active skyline these neighborhoods would
therefore be characterized by an act of
water line the resilience of these
neighborhoods would also require a
different approach to infrastructure
these buildings would be off the sewage
grid treatment wetlands would process
liquid waste in addition to vertical
circulation the bridge supports would
contain anaerobic digesters that would
process solid waste biogas produced by
each block could be used for cooking we
envisage the truth that the treatment
wetlands and access boardwalk to float
adapting to title change and sea level
rise comprise with modular concrete
elements these dynamic landscapes of
public spaces would also serve as
breakwaters attenuating wave energy in
the event of a storm surge the roofs
would function as a safe evacuation zone
new accra city addresses this paradox
that as sea levels rise the population
of New York is projected to increase but
running for the hills is a luxury we
can't afford to take and also an
opportunity can afford to miss therefore
we felt strongly that about proposing a
way to live with our future a kiss
condition any intervention in the harbor
should be systemic and work at both
environmental and social
bubbles but these systems may never need
to be deployed further out in the harbor
we propose a system of islands built
with modular elements submerged at a
maximum depth of 40 feet these islands
would support a network of inflatable
storm surge barriers that would fill
with water and air only in the event of
a storm surge more than 2,000 of these
density successfully deployed throughout
the world but we propose to use them as
a network between islands rather than as
a single line of defense for ninety-nine
percent of the time however they would
simply looked like this like Islands in
which sediment trap from the Hudson
during low tide would over time
instigate a new habitats and uses the
kind of infrastructure in disguise we
imagine archipelago therefore out in the
New York Harbor rather than a damn so as
a zoning ordinance for this fictional
city we presented nine points that have
guided us moving from City out of the
water one subway start the new actress
city from the city's existing
infrastructure two corridors incentivize
development corridors from land to water
selectively maintain and reuse sites
within a multi-use waterfront three
piers extend municipal peers to serve as
wave deflectors very stops and parks add
on to the water
for fairies implement an active ferry
service powered by biogas generated from
sewage the alte treatment plant
generates enough sewage to power one
ferry 25,000 miles every day five tram
placed the harbour at the center of the
new regional metropolis by connecting
the five boroughs to New Jersey with a
tram Harbor loop six islands build a
network of wave deflecting islands that
allows sediment to collect the natural
habitat to grow seven barriers link
these islands with dynamic inflatable
barriers to create a defensive line in
the event of a storm surge
eight Fergus networks utilized vacant
lots to create a pervious infiltration
network with swales as well that will
absorb strong water and directed back to
the harbor and finally nine aqueous
housing so new residential neighborhoods
that are resilient to sea level rise
I just have one thing to show
removed in aklan which is just a very
quick overview of the exhibition itself
i thought the slide would be useful to
show all three projects in fact ours on
the left on the right for wall panels
and you can see escapes in the distance
and to the left l.t.l.s there's a large
model by arrow on the left or slide as
well just briefly we had you know
decided to make four pieces each one at
which tested representational techniques
from its zoning and flow map that shows
an orange the kind of infrastructural
acupuncture or interventions to an axial
model that tries to look closely at one
of the hackers neighborhoods thank
okay thank you very and next is Mark
sake
I so as Reinhold mentioned I'm marks or
Makka I'm one of the partners of ltl
architects who were the team leaders for
site to as so designated rather cycle on
I've lost track as so designated by the
kind of curator of the exhibition our
team which I should mention because as
you may know all of these projects were
generated in a kind of team context in a
workshop format at ps1 included Aaron
forest Megan griscomb peril Indies
Kristen's daughter and Yasmine vobis the
the site that we were were given which
really became the sort of starting point
that kind of genesis of the project for
us was in a certain way unique among the
various sites and being unlike the the
portion of the harbor that eric has just
discussed relatively underutilized and
under populated with the majority of the
site which is located in the sort of
northwest corner of New York Harbor
comprising what is currently designated
as Liberty State Park the better specced
known aspects of the site of course and
the ones which are probably iconically
familiar to to everyone are the historic
islands of liberty and ellis islands
however the site is also characterized
by a series of smaller installations an
extent and historically significant
railroad terminal at the north end of
the site the CR and j terminal as well
as by the infrastructural monument of
the New Jersey Turnpike which really
sort of defines the western edge of the
site and divides it from the adjacent
urban neighborhood of Bergen lafayette
to the north of the site you have the
kind of recent development of exchange
place wall street west if you will which
currently includes the tallest building
in New Jersey the the goldman sachs
tower so what you have however in the
center of the site really the kind of
vast portion of the site is it is a
broad undeveloped territory so if this
is the familiar image that we all know
of the Statue of Liberty and Ellis
Island these historic sites the area
that really in the end interested us is
what you see in the kind of back of the
slide which is incredibly flat and
generally vacant tract of land that
comprises about 1,200 acres the the site
itself is almost as large about
three-quarters of the scale of Central
Park and is positioned actually in
greater proximity to lower Manhattan and
central park itself so one of the issues
that raised for us was the capacity of
this site to act as an incredible
resource as a kind of public or urban
amenity not only for New Jersey but also
for lower Manhattan the the edge of the
site portions of the edge of the site
have been developed starting around 1976
is Liberty State Park this is the kind
of current existing promenade along the
water featuring a kind of a batter sort
of riprap seawall edge however the
interior the site essentially looks like
this it's a kind of emergent wilderness
if you will which has some extremely
unique biological characteristics and
really is the residue of a kind of
industrial pass so this is the site to
just after the turn of the century and
one of the the initial exercises that we
did was to conduct a historical research
of the site beginning kind of look at it
its production really and what we what
we discovered was really the site is
really an entirely artificial construct
in its current status as land and
beginning about a hundred and fifty
years ago and the kind of kind of
colonial area of era the site
essentially didn't didn't exist it was
an estuary alot that was used by the
kind of local Hackensack Indians as a
kind of oyster harvesting area it was
extremely sort of shallow low-lying
terrain but essentially submerged under
the surface of the harbor beginning then
about 70 years ago the site was in
filled in a series of operations
primarily as a center for transshipment
sort of operations basically rail to
ship
it's fur and you can see here the kind
of successive building up of the site
from about 1862 about 1928 then it's
kind of current outline as it exists
today at the the kind of sort of apex of
the activity on the site in the early
20th century it's housed over a hundred
linear miles of rail rail yards a rail
trail railroad track and also the the
largest train shed in the world the
terminal at the north end of the site
where the 2010 arrow is pointing was
actually the point of access for about
two-thirds of the 12 million immigrants
who emigrated to this country came
through Ellis Island and the function as
really the the means of entry for them
into the interior of the United States
so the the irony of this is that if the
site didn't exist seventy years ago if
we look at the the next 70 to 80 years
is projected by the latrobe study that
really acts as the kind of foundation
for the rising currents project the site
will once again be essentially entirely
and undated the site will disappear if
nothing is done so if we look at even
conservative water level rise estimates
the kind of two foot water level rise
estimate about seventy seventy percent
of the site will be underwater with the
increasingly likely rapid ice melt
scenario of about a four foot level rise
which is actually what we ended up
utilizing as the parameter for our
project about eighty eighty percent of
the site is under water and in any of
the more radical storm surge events for
instance the hundred year flood which
will be occurring something more like
every 15 years with global climate
change about fully ninety-five percent
of the site is submerged so what you
have paradoxically is a site which
didn't exist which was essentially
produced as a result of
industrialization which is now the kind
of cause of its own demise if you will
so what our project attempts to do is is
in essence preserve this land for public
use and one of the dilemmas that we we
face on the site was that this this is
an area which I think even according to
the the study which
kind of a pre figure the rising currents
exhibition this site was essentially
allowed to simply disappear and in a way
this would not represent the kind of
economic or a sort of urban catastrophe
that say the erosion of lower Manhattan
would but we really were interested in
seeing how we could in a way take
advantage opportunistically of this
seemingly kind of catastrophic situation
to generate something kind of positive
as a kind of design proposal so what we
did in essence was too rather than
reinforce our kind of fortified the
existing singular edge of the site this
kind of crescent-shaped western edge we
selectively allow for the infiltration
of water into the site pulling in
essence the shoreline back into the
interior and producing a series of four
finger shaped landscape peers which are
then further crenellated along their
edges to produce a kind of sawtooth
interlocking between land and water what
this does effectively is to multiply the
length of the coastline by as much as 10
times its existing length so from an
existing coastline of about four and a
half miles we produce a new coastline a
kind of new boundary or kind of
threshold line between water and land of
approximately 45 miles at low tide this
does two really critical things for us
one is that it allows us the site to
operate as a more resilient and porous
buffer for storm surge events and for
sea level rise in general but it also
maximizes the intertidal zone as a kind
of a testing ground for new uses in
habitations based on the dynamic
interchange or exchange between land and
water so the the operation importantly
is not about say importing or exporting
material to the site and it's really
about a kind of conservation of matter
if you will operating through a kind of
cut and fill logic so if this is the
existing section of the site as I said
extraordinarily flat and easily
inundated with relatively kind of modest
increases in sea level what we're
proposing as a sectional reefs culp ting
of this historic fill the kind of
topography of the site through a series
of subtle shifts which would allow for
areas to remain
protected with the four level sea level
rise and a series of new kind of
channelization zeeeee which would allow
for waddled water to infiltrate this
site in a more controlled fashion the
other aspect of this is to really
produce through these kinds of sloping
surfaces a more dynamic interchange
between the surface of the land and the
surface of the harbor essentially
resulting in a kind of experimental
terrain which would be in a kind of
constant state of fluctuation and change
relative to both the sort of diurnal
shifts of the of the tide of the harbor
which which changes as much as four to
five feet in this area as well as the
longer range projected change over the
course of the next 70 years the site is
further activated then through a series
of what we call programmatic anchors
which occupy the terminus of each of
these landscape fingers and which
augment the kind of touristic functions
of Ellis and Liberty Islands essentially
acting as a tractors for activity and
public inhibit and habitation into the
site they ask also function to to
connect or to link the site itself into
both the adjacent territory and the kind
of larger context of the region and the
harbor through an enhanced network of
aquatic and terrestrial transportation
secondarily a series of loose
programmatic territories then kind of
cross we've kind of counter grain to the
kind of primary directionality of the
piers essentially resulting in a kind of
diverse mix of uses a kind of
combination of productive landscape and
public park research and recreation the
zones are starting from the top a kind
of agricultural zone for experimental
agrarian installations a recreational
zone which would continue the public and
kind of current aspect of the site as it
as a form of public landscape or Park a
remediation zone which would allow for
the containment and treatment of the
more sort of toxic soils on the site
there is a site is in many ways of
brownfield due to its history of
industrial use preserve which would
begin to which would allow for the kind
of survival or the kind of continuation
of some of the unique a sort of species
comedy
shins and kind of biological conditions
of the site as well as a series of
constructed wetlands a research zone
which would again contain these sort of
experimental programs at an agricultural
zone which would look at the idea of the
harbor as a new sort of productive space
so the resulting plan which you see here
is really a sort of new form of
amphibious landscape which would sort of
combine in a very sort of Frank way the
kind of natural and the infrastructural
so we are interested in the idea that
this site is not an either a wholly
artificial site nor a wholly organic one
and that the kind of resulting condition
of the design really seeks to merge
these properties and to kind of take
advantage of them both the other is that
it's organized according to a series of
modules which we called petri dishes
which in essence are a series of
wedge-shaped inclined planes which
produce a kind of organizational module
for the various landscapes and programs
that inhabit the site these are each
structured essentially as a kind of a
sloping territory with diverse degrees
of engagement with between the water and
the land so essentially you have hard
edge separations and remediation zones
where we need the kind of containment of
soils for instance to kind of more
gradual kind of sloping fields of
estuary exchange for aqua parks
aquaculture and agricultural aspects of
the site they also kind of link into a
new network of circulation which is both
vehicular but also pedestrian engaging
bicycles and watercraft on the site as
well and we are interested in also
developing relationships of kind of flow
and kind of performative
interdependencies within each of these
territories they're all then sort of
developed relative two very different
engagements with the water so all of
these begin to perform very differently
in terms of how they they kind of relate
the kind of space of the harbor and the
space of the park and
and our terrorist and kind of sculpted
in kind of modified form and then mapped
against the possibilities and the
proclivities of the different
programmatic ideas that we wanted to
sort of see emerge on the site so that
the kind of net effect of this is to
produce a landscape sort of shown here
in this sequence of slides which is not
conceived as a static Cena graphic Park
according to the kind of 18th century
model but rather as a kind of active and
continually transforming landscape which
would be sort of sort of engaged and
really sort of made dynamic in
perpetuity by this kinds of
transformational relationships of the
tide and that would occur not only
through the kind of twice daily shift
within tidal cycles but also over longer
periods of time relative to processes of
deposition and erosion which we would
sort of see actively kind of engaging
with in the context of the project
speaking a little bit to the
representation of the project within the
context of the exhibition we're also
faced with a really interesting dilemma
which is that the the site is really
thought about primarily in in sections
right really through a series of
sectional operations but those
operations are really primarily visible
through their effects and plan so like a
beach for instance a very subtle shift
of a few feet begins to enact a radical
transformation in the kind of
planimetric dimension so what we did was
to construct a kind of topographic model
which would act as a kind of projection
surface for an animation similar to the
kind of slide sequence that i just
showed in which will allow the public to
sort of engage and understand the way
this is not a kind of a single
proposition a singular landscape but
really a kind of constantly shifting and
involving design we also devised a
series of aerial panoramic views which
would seek to kind of show the site from
the water side starting from the the
southern portion of the site working to
the north the landscape here that
terminates in the in an aquaculture
research and development center further
inland or a series of marine hatcheries
and hydrological testing facilities that
correspond to the research program of
the site the structure itself is a kind
of pier like construction which hovers
over the water and suspends a series of
floating walkways that define research
beds for the testing of various species
within the context of New York Harbor
further to the north an amphitheater
which would continue the function of the
site as it currently exists as a venue
for large-scale outdoor performances
they hold already kind of large-scale
concerts here however in our variation
on this these performances would be
visible not only from the land side but
also from the water by a series of
camping barges and nearby marina so for
us it was incredibly important that the
the not Nolan not only the land but also
the surface of the water itself would be
understood really as a public space that
could be activated programmatically
further inland on this finger are a
series of tidal parks comprising beaches
pools and islands which would appear and
disappear with the fluctuations of the
time the next finger a water launch
which will allow for a longer term and
habitation of the site which merges with
the adjacent terrain at one end in a
series of pools and terraces and rises
out of the the water on the other to a
shelter marina for kayaks and other
human powered vehicles that would allow
for the exploration of the various
landscapes on the interior of the site
by a series of water trails and elevated
pedestrian boardwalks and then finally
at the northernmost pier of the site
we're proposing repurposing the existing
central railroad of New Jersey terminal
historic terminal into a regional
markets which would distribute both
produce from local farms in the
surrounding territory but also crops
grown on the site which we envision
actually functioning as a kind of
agricultural testing zone for a saline
and flood resistant crops actually one
of the kind of critical issues with sea
level rise globally is that many of the
territories near the near the water in
these coastal regions are not only
inhabited but many are very productive
agrarian zones so
destination of large areas of farmland
would be another result of this and we
envisioned the kind of existing terminal
sheds extending from their kind of
current limit and as a series of
research buildings and public markets
and interweaving with a series of new
testing fields which would allow for the
development of species that would be
more resistant to inundation in the kind
of advent of these these events so in
conclusion the the site that rather the
project is intentionally ambitious and
depending upon the kind of productive
and optimistic role of design and
intended to function not only as a
demonstration of possibilities within
New York Harbor as a new form of public
landscape but also as a prototype for
conditions seem to be faced globally by
many similar coastal areas and I'll stop
there thank you hey thank you Mark and
Kate or okay I'll take the first slide
got it got it got it got it okay hi it's
showing on my screen okay so I'm Kate
and I teach here and I'm very excited to
present this project in the in the
Columbia context with this terrific
audience the title of our project is
called oyster texture and it was
interesting that Eric showed the the
sort of brief you know that we had we
all went to these interviews at the
Museum and during my interview I
basically for better for worse laid out
a kind of a critique of the ghee nordson
report that was kind of serving as the
brief for the project so luckily that
went well could have gone badly but but
you know what I come to this project
with is is an interest that you know the
sort of typical architectural motifs and
strategies may not necessarily apply to
something like rising tides or rising
currents as it's called so you know with
a sense that you know humans have kind
of participated in the sort of aggregate
way to generate excess carbon in the
atmosphere through melt multiple
millions of small actions and now
there's not really necessarily a big
infrastructural fix for a sort of an
architectural fix that can help get us
out of it so my concept was really to
frame the entire project through the
frame of living beings animals and
people and to try to sort of organize
those behaviors in a different way to
engage the issues so we had this
terrific team of here Ben Alice Steve
and Angela Steven who I hope you've
worked with here Angela and an Gina
three colombia to Harvard and we also
partnered with veneer harbor school the
guy institute some professors at
columbia and a graphic design firm we
were given this site red hook and the
canal and governors island and if you'll
notice see there's not a pointer right
here in the middle is this kind of large
blue landform that immediately caught my
eye that's called the Bay Ridge flats
and so one of the first things we did
actually was to take a boat ride with
our partners this is Pete Malinowski an
oyster farmer and teacher at the harbor
school out to the the Bay Bridge flats
and sort of check out the water another
thing we did was really to sort of look
back at the history of the site because
for me coming coming out of them a
background of liberal arts philosophy
and history I really feel like history
is a tool you know it's as powerful as
any tool because it sort of puts this
entire project within a trajectory of
land form and behavior and our
interaction with the harbor so we did it
sort of history of our site and you can
see that you know it was really is kind
of Governors Island which is now part of
Manhattan was really part of this just
arcing ring of islands that served as a
kind of a natural breakwater for upland
Brooklyn that was settled at the time
the lowlands remain incredibly
productive salt marshes they had the
Gowanus actually had you know Auster's
the size of dinner plates and you know
it was a very different kind of
topographical signature so he learned a
lot from just this typographical
signature and how the lowlands were
incredibly productive settlement occurs
on the upland and and that this creates
a sort of a very positive dynamic
between settlement and water so the
situation of the the Gowanus now is
quite different course in the sort of
industrial boom of New York most of
these and marshy areas were dredged and
catalyzed to uniform width and were in
the case the Gowanus dotted with
manufactured gas plants oil refineries
many a whole range of different toxins
so for us sea level rise and this is you
know our 2080 line here is is
incredibly important from a public
health standpoint because you have these
active communities which would be
essentially affected by the further
dispersal of these contaminants and and
just after we completed the project the
Gowanus was listed as an EPA Superfund
site so I really felt like not just the
key here isn't just to address rising
currents but really to start to address
three things first is water quality
because if you know Vietnam right
there's the way that the sort of
landscape works the inundation of the
rice fields the houses built to a
certain level it's a relatively good
water quality so it's not catastrophic
if the floods occur it's actually quite
a positive thing so water quality is a
sort of a key piece that's missing here
secondly storm surge and thirdly
Seabrook would level rise became or kind
of program so again with this notion of
looking at the frame of living beings we
thought to address water quality with
the sort of a biotic component with
oysters eelgrass and mussels oysters
specifically and mussels have incredible
filtration capacity to address to storm
surge through this new land form
mimicking the historic historic land for
him out and the in the bay at the Bay
Ridge flats and we called this Palisades
be Bay reef State Park and dressing sea
level rise with a sort of a new Gowanus
fabric so it's kind of calling our
project back to the future and here are
those 3s three elements instrument
overall view so first first of all this
this notion of water quality New York
used to be a slow harbor with clean
water and and it was a very active
Harbor so what happened I mean oysters
used to actually cover about twenty-five
percent I'm sorry osters used to cover
yeah at least twenty-five percent of the
entire Bay and are now one percent of
their former levels but this oyster is
an amazing animal because it's you know
through through its kind of marvel of
this beautiful digestive tract it can
accept algae detritus and pollutants and
outside the other end comes clean or
water you can literally dip a tray
moist earth in an algae filled tank and
half an hour later remove that and the
tank is clear so all these oysters were
actually capable of filtering the water
in the harbor in a matter of days we're
also interested in the sort of culture
of oysters because for me I was
particularly focused on the format of
the moma being something that has a
public component to it it's not a
project that I'm showing you
architecture students although i'm doing
that now but but but it was very
exciting to me to kind of start to try
to use history to reach a broader
audience and get some sort of you know
get my get my hands in and get get get
really people sort of focus on the
situation now and what it is that they
can do so royster carts were actually
once as popular as the hotdog carts are
today and the second thing that oysters
do is they can agglomerate and to form
barriers and natural seed see barriers
and reefs are the number one kind of
barrier that creates the most effective
wave attenuation because it reaches it
starts deep in the water column and it
reaches up and so that velocity which
starts deep in the water column is then
attenuated and finally with sea level
rise we're interested in this notion of
kind of creating new habitats not only
for for animals but for people and i
don't know if i'm sure many of you know
this from your own research but New York
is and Jamaica Bay and the New York
Harbor is a sort of crucial stopover for
migratory birds this board unfortunately
is the American Oystercatcher and is
almost you know is in steep decline so
we were inspired by like this Easter
right because of its qualities its scale
or property the scalar properties the
one the agglomeration and we're also
inspired by actually the life cycle of
the oyster because what we learned was
that only a very short amount of time
and you know there's this you know you
don't need or stirs in the summer
they're all these kind of months with
our they're all these kind of rules that
that we know when we not to eat oysters
and that's because they're in the sort
of reproductive phase but it's a good a
constant reproductive phase and they
move from a sort of a fertilized egg to
a free swimming
lar vie to a spat which is the moment in
the oysters lifecycle when it kind of is
swimming around and looking for
something to attach to to an adult male
and female in a very short amount of
time so we looked at this life cycle as
being kind of you know an inspiration at
this larger site scale and we thought
about our whole site as being this cycle
of regeneration based on this life cycle
that could continue to build and grow
this kind of new community-based sort of
involvement and also a renewed sort of
ecosystem here so we have our shell
recycling the flushing the flushing
tunnel becomes the beginning of our
flexi process and I'll talk about that
in a minute flushing cleaner water
through the gowanus canal where we have
our nursery and then those oysters fat
are then paraded down the gowanus canal
in these low low bottom boats and then
seated out in the reef so you have kind
of a cycle of regenerating life and you
also have the opposite happening which
is that the reef then in turn protects
the inland Gowanus community so so
that's the results really and so we
started to develop this reef structure
because the the hardware as you also
know has been dredged and catalyzed
within an inch of its sort of life and
one of the things we did was work with
Paul Mike Witts to try to visualize what
the structure could be and so one day he
came into my studio and dropped and you
know a big a ton of this fuzzy rope on
my floor and we realized that this rope
could actually be woven together and
make kind of a soft infrastructure that
would help spur the the development of
this reef and so we began to think about
knitting this fabric and within a sea of
piles that could be able to create this
kind of sort of semi soft heart
infrastructure so and you know just as
an aside we all learned how to actually
knit because we we needed our
so this is how the wave attenuation
barrier works with a sort of a grid of
marine piles and and bring this sort of
woven fabric from low in the water
column up to the surface and and
basically working with piles of rocks
and Shoals to fully dissipate the wave
energy before it hits go on us and
that's what it it looks like and a key
part of this is because the harbor has
been so decimated by dredging that
oysters when they do actually find
something to an attached to they become
sedimented out and covered with silt so
that's a key physical aspect of what our
fabric does is it holds the oysters
above this sediment zone and our idea to
was that this oyster oyster texture
would then grow and evolve with
alongside the threat of climate change
so here's a kind of diagram of this glom
eration of the reef and the sort of
development of new public space because
of course on the other hand what I'm
really most interested in is this notion
of this kind of new watery public space
that's created this for blue network of
sort of the the this is my sort of back
to the future moment of how we used to
sort of interact with the harbor and so
you basically creating this sort of
water / land zone of boats people
animals this is a view of our model and
one of the sort of research and dive
stations there
so the main thing that that this does
also is create a new kind of central
green lanten blue landscape which is
really you know the the kind of
contemporary version or that the sort of
Braveheart Waterworld version of park
space for the next century so as you saw
our exhibit was really we basically just
said we're just going to do a section so
we because this section as you heard me
explain is really the part of the key
idea that the this interactivity between
upland and inland in water and upland so
here's a section showing this wave
action being dissipated the sort of
public space that results this the
calmer water in the Red Hook canal now
and then finally to the Gowanus so I'm
going to talk a little bit about to go
on as canal now this is what it looks
like today with these semi viable
industries that don't use the water on
its edges with sewage dumping regularly
into the canal at CSO events and so
we're really just Reese Culp ting that
land and he here is adding this kind of
fluff see path the other trick with the
Gowanus is that you cannot access it
right there's no right way along the
edge so we're creating kind of a right
away within the water productive right
away within the water zone and key to
this entire system and I never know
where to put this slide because you need
it first and you need it last is this
fluff SI system which is called a
floating upwelling system it's really a
sort of a nursery oyster nursery where
little baby oysters are contained in
these chambers water is pumped through
so it's like force feeding the oysters
and thousands and thousands and
thousands of baby oysters are produced
and then are protected from predators so
that's our thought was that basically we
re envisioned this entire Gowanus as a
as a fluff see with the sort of turbine
moving this water through that exists
that exists now water through and that
we would basically take advantage of
that existing technology so this is our
flops ification diagram flexa fication
in public space one of the many new
words that we had to invent and we
really felt like post Superfund that
that this project would really be able
to be effective in terms of providing a
kind of a restoration plan for this zone
so here's one of those CSO gardens the
oyster the oyster nursery and then
finally this notion of you know
anticipating because the first thing
that anyone asks me regardless is when
can I eat the oysters and the answer is
not yet we did some calculations we
think it's like 20-30 2050 but basically
that the sort of oyster is don't don't
eat the oyster he's working and finally
this notion of celebrating which is you
know really what we were trying to work
with and actually how we there's a
million I mean I'm sure my fellow
participants can attest to the mountains
of work left on the table but and you
know we also devised the sort of system
of participation within the reef but one
of the key things is also this notion of
like parading down the oysters fat down
to the down to the reef and the way that
that really kind of works with the
Gowanus community and finally
celebrating and eating and this is our
sort of this is our dystopian brave new
world view of the Gowanus in 20 20 50
when you can actually enjoy a tasty
Gowanus oyster thank you
ok we're going to turn on the light
there's work to do this is the real work
in a sense I'm just kidding but the know
just to thank first of all our you know
I have to say that these guys have been
doing so much work after after the
exhibition I've never seen an exhibition
they're doing a boat tour tonight has
been all series advance in the
discussions and and so we do have to
make this stimulating for our guests i
also i did want to thank anna ken off
for helping to put a hold this together
you'll get to know and ask the program
coordinator of the fuel center as we
continue with here but for now let's
just maybe i'll just ask andrea to you
know elaborate on his question first and
then see where it goes and then i'll try
to developing yeah i mean i have one
brief question them and i have many
versions in case the question doesn't go
through but it's ryan home basically
mentioned the the manish is beta key to
try and see the argument that you're
racing through the work you you produced
through the projects so the question is
basically like beyond the specificity of
the of the site and the operation and
tactics that you proposed for the site
and for the problem of the rising
currents to what extent what you say
you've also exploited the projects for
the production of a number of arguments
for the field in other words for
envisaging other forms of architecture
and other forms of urbanism in other
words he has an incubator for new
architecture and new ideas about the
city
okay I'll start no and I think it's a
really great question in the sense that
it raises one of the dilemmas of the
exhibition from the outset which is in
the one hand we were given this very
particular charge to address rising
water levels in a series of specific
sites around New York Harbor on the
other hand the context was a you know
moma right which comes with certain
demands and expectations in terms of
what you're presenting and as kate was
just discussing also the kind of
question of audience of who you're
addressing and how you're addressing
them and so the the condition was such
that from our standpoint talking a
little bit about our our project in
particular we felt that that in essence
the the question of rising currents
could be in any way completely obviated
on our site in other words the psychic
disappear no one would kind of cry over
it as long as the historic monuments
were preserved and so for us it really
became a kind of impetus or a kind of
catalyst for beginning to think about a
new way of thinking about a large-scale
public landscape that addressed a sort
of more active dynamic and performative
component relative relative to let's say
similar large-scale urban proposals that
have occurred over the course of the
last 20 25 years and and you know many
of the many of these these conditions
then became seen through the lens of the
operation of the kind of engagement of
the
water really as a kind of sort of major
element on the one hand that was a kind
of tactical condition that was relative
to the project but for us it also became
a more general way to rethink the way
that we could understand the
relationship between cities landscapes
and the kind of you know quote-unquote
natural condition of the harbor right
and also to look at maybe the invocation
of natural and artificial systems
through the the kind of device of of the
exhibition as well as the content of our
particular site which is we were sort of
talking a bit about is already kind of
complex imprecation of those systems so
it's a site that now is perceivable as a
natural kind of condition but in fact
was generated through a series of of
industrial and artificial processes
every time I guess in my case I had also
come to the project having just written
like a really long essay about Jamaica
Bay which maybe some of you know here in
the New York Harbor but this is big
estuary down by JFK Airport and it's
this really kind of a watershed
questions so it sounds but but taking
lessons that I was learning from Jamaica
Bay and the snow she is for me
translated into the oyster texture
project and and and what I really kind
of took out of it was this idea of scale
as a strategy and I don't know because
because I feel like we all struggled
with this notion of being given a site
right so your site is inheritable
parently sort of demonstrative of
something but at the same time you know
in my office we have big sites and small
sites but this still your you're always
struggling with your boundaries in a
sense and actually being able to effect
change so for me I really came out of
oyster texture rising currents with this
motion
of scale and being able to kind of
understand and articulate architectural
strategies that are scalar and can be
scaled up I think the question is very
difficult because it puts us in the
position potentially of trying to
evaluate the resonance of our projects
beyond the specific constraints or no
issues that we were trying to address
right but it also can be seen as a set
of intentions I mean I think all three
projects we've seen are attempting
through the specific you know
understanding of the site you know to
solve or address issues that are global
or at least have larger scale
ramifications or that could be systemic
and so therefore maybe the project is
either capital P or small pee in your
question larger project of architecture
yeah but I mean it's you know you can't
get to a systemic or general idea
without looking something very closely
specifically but an architect's our
approach was from the beginning just not
really well and I think I should say
that each of our sites certainly
influenced the trajectory of each of our
projects I mean if ltl had had our site
what they have you know looked at the
sectional variation is not necessarily
and similarly the case but our site was
very large the largest one we had a
large variety of conditions and it
clearly we're inclined to look at it as
sort of urban systemic set of conditions
we might have been inclined to think of
a zoning resolution but I think the
scale of it definitely influenced you
know Babs over
I can go to the second okay yeah i mean
the second question has to do basically
it's bigger yeah the second question has
to do basically with the question of the
edge and and i basically as far as i
understand the problem was post in such
a way that you had to rethink the edge
but basically looking outwards it's
basically the heir to the relation of
the city the edge of the city with the
water and potentially there the idea of
envisaging a new for public space by
embracing the water i thought there was
a kind of a kind of open reference to
venice at some point i remember from
previous presentation so the question I
have basically since you you can of all
work with with edges which are kind of
diluted were basically that welcome the
water in all three projects what is the
relationship you establish between the
edge and the inside in other words the
the language the edge defines a known
its relation to the water but its
relation to the city and in so doing
what kind of urbanism do you propose
it's a crucial question if I could take
it first our collaborators mathura
takuna have spent a lot of time looking
at the kind of extensive gradient of
what we now call the edge that really
there isn't a single edge it's dynamic
it's shifting and it's something in our
thinking that's been produced by the
evolution of planning of the plan and
the map right but in fact if we think of
it as a continuous at europe after ariel
condition this possibly changing there
is no single edge but ultimately you
know we tried to address this issue
through a dynamic condition and a
multiple condition in other words there
are many edges is you know can a
pervious network that extends all the
way into the city so if i try to trying
to bring the city to the water in the
water into the city we try to confound
that very very issue but the edge also i
think is a disciplinary edge that is
brought up here and there what are the
tools and you know histories and so on
we need to corral to address address
this issue and clearly
each project has exposed so I'm thinking
that you know transcends or transgresses
I think that kind of us too i would say
that maybe the edge is problematic as a
starting point because of the the edges
is the battleground to some degree but
but it assumes some sort of adaptive
that we're already in kind of that
architecture can really just adapt and I
don't know I me because I feel like the
issues with sea level rise are generated
from surface for the most part and the
effects are felt inland and I most
visibly demonstrated on the edge so
although you know so I would say this
notion of just architects you know
making soft edges is something that I
think we landscape architects and we've
been doing for many years but it doesn't
really address the core issues even
though it addresses some issues in that
people interacting with the water I
think is the first sense that things
might change or that things could change
because you know certainly the edges of
Manhattan and Brooklyn and many parts of
New Jersey have been bulk headed and so
that's contributed to a sort of ricochet
effect of faster water dirtier water and
so on so so clearly the edge has a role
to play but it's not it's sort of lit
pre pre defines the role of Architects
in this adaptive design I think the the
dilemma of the edge is being sort of
laid out by my colleagues was in a way
precisely what what we began to sort of
focusing on but not really in a way
through its kind of miss recognition
within the project in other words that
the the notion of edge which which even
the term as I think kids are learning to
presupposes the notion of a definitive
limit in some point between you know or
vanity and the kind of natural system or
between disciplinary operations etc in
our case it became really interesting to
start looking at kind of specifics of
edge and I think there's a broad way in
which the rising currents are projects
are often kind of categorized as a kind
of softening of the kind of hard
infrastructure led to the harbor which i
think is generally speaking true about
all of the work that we did however I
think there is this if you begin to look
at the kind of tectonics of the edge the
way it's going to developed over time
and the kind of multiplicity of ways in
which land and water can kind of engage
we became much more interested in say
deploying varying techniques through the
kind of project that could begin to
allow for different interrelationships
between the kind of land and the harbor
to exist and and in ways that would
address varying conditions with the site
but also generate different human and
programmatic interactions between the
public aspect of the of the park itself
and the kind of the harbor as another
kind of a public space and you know for
us there is this kind of really
interesting change which is that the the
edge is usually understood in plant
understood as it going to play and
figure but if you look at it in section
it becomes a much more sort of
complicated operation and the other
thing that I think everyone is
addressing is that the temporal
condition here and we're talking about
scale moment ago but I think scale
applies here to kind of a time scale as
well as a physical scale that that for
us it was a really great opportunity to
begin to think about the kind of
fluctuation of edge not and not in a
kind of singular way but
in a way that actually berries this
variable and kind of convoluted kind of
try to develop this a little bit so I
mean in a way I really just wanted to
ask you how your projects work but not
so much and you know in the sense of the
intricate detail with which we've been
that you know in which you've described
them but but how they work as projects
like you know these things are not going
to get built I mean that's that's what
we we presume from the beginning so
we're not necessarily that's the fixture
the fiction part is maybe more important
than the science part in some in this
functional understanding of the project
where where what matters is not directly
hopefully indirectly but not directly
the actual realization of these projects
right so in that sense they're they're
different than your classic modernist
you know urban plan there a couple of
ways in which they did they even on a
tabula rasa site they reject tabula rasa
strategies right the site is historicize
constructed deconstructed you know
elaborated in all kind as an artifact
and as part of the project rather than
is simply kind of blank slate the other
thing so in that sense the you know
wonderful you know drawings that all of
you showed even though they share some
of the characteristics of a kind of you
know broadacre city master plan or
VF ideas or those kinds of large-scale
managing the documents that have
historically be used to project visions
of cities along the lines that Enrique
is asking actually their realism and
their it you know is sort of paradoxical
right because what's real about these
things is they're fictional character
and and that seems incredibly
instrumental here if the instrumentality
is to be understood is like basically
getting people like the ddc and
everybody else to talk about this stuff
to deal with it to confront this this
problem okay so that that's a little bit
what I mean but I just to give it a
little more depth and perspective I
imagine I mean one of the things that
visa vie the edge question with the
documents that you can everybody here
can go visit actually it's in the
library you can you have to go deep into
the library i don't know i invite you to
do that one day where the books are and
somewhere there you will find a print of
paradises couple mark CEO plan which is
a historical it's a kind of monument to
a certain way of thinking about a city
which has persisted in the architectural
imagination really up till I'd say about
eighteen nineteen eighty-four 90s the
city as a collection of artifacts it's a
marshal de Marshall that this are the
marshlands of Rome so we moved from
Venice to Rome reimagined through the
archaeological imagination of Paran AC
basically by a kind of science fiction
reconstruction of what Rome used to be
sort of but never really as a future
projection of a kind of you know imagine
city made of very very tightly bounded
hyper articulated
trickle a complex artifacts right now
again and in responsibly you know this
is these projects all of them including
the ones the others in the exhibition
seem to say there is no such city
anymore or if there is such a city it's
in the background it's the city of
skyscrapers and grids and so on that is
New York it's the city of self-contained
artifacts instead we live now in the
city of blurry edges of gradients of
nature culture hybridity and so on so
there's no more nature so the mart where
is paranasal could project the city of
human artifice on them against the
background of a marsh like you know kind
of you know nature this city these
cities require some other relationship
between humans and nature even before
you design them they imagine that and
they protect that so okay that's enough
of a kind of frame then what about this
this problem of like this sort of
science fiction character of the work
because one of the things I think
compels us to to reimagine our world in
a way that you've been doing is the
catastrophic let's say consequence of
the humans to nature opposition that
ecology tries to undermine all you know
various sort of fireman's discourse has
been dealing with so you know in other
words if that if what we're dealing with
is a kind of historical catastrophe and
the consequence for architecture is nice
waterfronts
what about what what about this sort of
darker side of the science fiction I
know you some of you've alluded to draw
it out a little bit you know the dead
bodies floating up from Philadelphia
basically and and that because that's
really what we're talking I mean
metaphor the real future
I would say I mean I think that that's
one of the major critiques you know of
the situation but I mean and what what
I'm fighting against always is this
notion that once we discovered global
warming it was already too late to think
so so I took a position in our project
which is like to not visualize a future
you have to do that to some degree but
to not project a visualization of a
future that is a kind of a bubble and
the horizon but to show sets of tools
and attitudes and approaches that could
get one from here to there and it was
actually I don't want to say it was a
kind of a communication strategy but but
to some degree I felt like our project
evolved into an architectural
exploration that was equal parts
communication and equal parts but I
think there is a culture within the
residency itself that already kind of
presuppose more optimistic attitude the
resident you have to explain residency
so they don't understand basically is
that this is a whole yeah it was like
Top Chef and project runway combines a
reality show no none of these project
that you see are you know typical of any
of our practices I at least speaking for
ourselves in any way i would say some
are somewhere between a project in our
office a studio here at columbia and
something else and there are other
actors these the people who actually did
most of the work who are not here with
us today but there's a culture of
optimism i think that was already you
know inscribed within the latrobe study
that within all the sort of meetings we
had i think there was a general tendency
with you know for all of us to shy away
from the kind of description of dystopia
that I think is already commandeered by
the medium and show another kind of
approach that is instrumental at some
level whether or not it's solving or
ever will solve real problems but the
ending with the word you started your
long question with
was it was how do you know how do they
work your panties and I guess the word
work if we return to it I mean and
unpack it a little bit i mean on the one
hand how is it instrumental as a
solution how does it work as a project
how does it all together conceptually or
what's the elegance the rigor of it or
how does it work as an enduring image
yeah you'd be surprised though the
extent to which the city agency people
like Amanda burden our Commissioner of
planning and other people are actually
very interested in in these things and
they're attending a lot of our you know
boat tours and talking to us and saying
well no we're actually you know gonna
you know initiate studies and see to
what extent some of these solutions or
you know it just could in fact be
addressed but I don't think any of us
said or you know thought well here's a
solution that's global I think it's seen
as a provocation and and in our instance
rather than describing a scenario just a
single image of the future and and the
weakest part of our project to be
counted for a second i think is the one
image that is an image you know and I
and I regret that one but I mean well
there's some there's a rendering which I
never want to show again but we what I'm
comfortable with I think and you know
I'm revealing a little bit of complexity
of the whole project is not something in
our office that we can totally control
but what I'm really more comfortable
with i think is the the list of zoning
recommendations that is just more of a
provocation like how can we deal with
this as a problem that is much larger
than about an edge that is a social
issues there's about water quality
whatever you know you just bring up that
is a huge huge problem so it defies the
elegant diagrammatic solution of some of
the other projects we might you know I
aspire to back to the question of how
this works in the context of an
exhibition in MoMA and as I kind of
I think the idea for us that was on the
one hand difficult which is that yes in
this kind of science fictional
projection that in the end is a fiction
in the sense that none of us really
knows the determinacy of this outcome
that there's a high degree of ambiguity
even if you know that we all buy into
the particular premise of what the
specifics of how this will play out
would be there was a sort of necessary
impetus I think to conceive about the
production of image so i think the
status of image here that Eric's
alluding to is was extremely problematic
one because we knew that we had to
generate work that would be legible by a
broader public this was not sort of
intended simply as a either a series of
technical solutions which frankly we are
not necessarily the people to propose in
the most efficient way nor was it wasn't
understood as a kind of theoretical
Haemon conceptual lecture exercise it
was understood as a as in a certain
level not to put it to bluntly but as a
visualization that would engage a larger
public within the kind of the kind of
debater that kind of discourse
surrounding this as well as agencies and
and sort of the apartments for instance
the city planning components that are
being referred to here in ways that they
may not be engaged in a more academic
discourse so I think that that was
intriguing crust because on the one hand
we would resist I think and I think we
all probably had a certain resistance to
producing say solutions that where were
in a way overly defined or produced
simply a kind of a kind of iconic and
kind of recognized
image along the lines of the kinds of
historical architectural antecedents
that you're referring to on the other
hand it had to be engaging in a way that
it could be conveyed to that audience as
well as sort of offer a kind of
provocation that this was not to take a
kind of dystopian circumstance right the
kind of projected scenario sea level
rise and turn it into something sort of
engaging and optimistic so that it
wouldn't simply be kind of ignored so
there was a level of invention I guess
we also felt that as architects are our
kind of role could be to bring a degree
of of invention and in certain level a
level of paradoxically a kind of
pleasure into visualizing what this this
seemingly kind of negative scenario
might be and just as a quick follow-up
to the sort of human natural dialogue
that that you set out to I mean I feel
like one of the things that that we were
interested in engaging is you know
obviously it immediately provokes the
limits of discussion of the limits of
architecture right and like the limits
of a museum exhibition about
architecture where you see a painting by
zaha hadid in a frame and you kind of
get it or you don't get it and you move
on because I mean clearly the global
warming and sea level rise have been you
know created as a result of human
behavior and therefore require behavior
change to be mediated in any
way so the the role of architecture I
sink ships from one that is illustrative
or of a project to one that is
generative of a behavior change to some
degree so I also feel like the output of
the show or of you in the next 20-30
years will be you know will be will be
successful based on those merits I have
another question I I mean as far as I
understand yeah Oh shall we okay as far
as I understand the the brief basically
mentioned Venice deliberately as a
suppressant basically the idea of
imagining public space through the water
I mean I as far as i remember from the
presentation of movement he not just
noticed and basically mentioned that my
question is pasted to what extent did
you welcome and celebrate the the idea
of let's say rethinking New York I
events and to what extent do you
basically as New Yorkers resistive at
and the question being that I think it's
actually a delicate reference Venice
today because of the fact that women
hadn't exactly becoming Venice itself
the fact that is gradually becoming come
a terrific play ground and probably the
High Line being the ultimate symptom of
that of that condition so the question
would be to what extent do you celebrate
them to what extent do you kind of
debate the question of Venice as a
mobile one of the key clues about our
position on that would be a shift in
thinking from land centric Manhattan
centric understanding of the city to
aqueous right so if and this was
actually a provocation that
you know getting artisans a book already
provided us what if the center of New
York were to shift to the upper bay so
in other words it's you know it's no
longer an island that's they
figuratively or figure Lee we are now
inverting that condition so Venice is as
a model in that sense that you know it's
no longer kind of isn't so in other
words I think those of us who cling to a
certain image of Manhattan would find
these projects sort of terrible
softening in a sense of a very kind of
wonderful city but sometimes let's think
of it as a regional condition that's
fluctuating that has many new dynamic
connections and so on so I think that's
how we pushed
only one project deals of Manhattan I'm
sorry Justin it's a are rose project so
it has any wasn't shown today the
project you've seen are dealing with
Brooklyn and Staten Island and New
Jersey that's right
I don't I mean I think what in talking
about the broader audience for the
exhibit I mean we we sort of felt like
the audience's really global global
cities but I don't know it could be
because I it's really incredible when
you start to research you know the sheer
percentage of population that lives in
you know below at sea level or within
sort of the threat of the sort of you
know 50 year inundation period Delta
cities that but maybe that you know the
projects could be powerful relative to
some of these other global cities that
are going to be facing some of the same
issues and I think ideally that one
could you know go through the exhibit
and synthesize a set of techniques out
of the five projects that that could be
you utilize like a toolbox in any city
inland or water water based right after
Katrina via I forget the exact name of
the body but the American Society of
Civil Engineers i think it was made a
visit to the netherlands to look at the
delta project which so far i think is
still the largest infrastructure project
on earth bigger than the three gorges
dam and the delta projects basically
response to sea level rises but mostly
storm surges throughout holland
southwest Holland Zeeland specifically
and it's comprised of a series of
barriers and actually we took our
Columbia students there are two years
ago the options to do students but so I
think any solution has transfer
possibility of being trapped you know
transfer to another set of conditions
but clearly there's a set of specific
conditions the ostrich held a barrier
just prior to its completion in
one was made to be permeable when they
realized that the ecosystem of the you
know the estuary would just be
completely destroy so they let the water
seep in and out just a little bit and it
that was only possible because it lasted
so it took so long to build decades
businesses so the thinking is you know
but I think that you know each of the
projects is scalable or at least you
know contains elements that could be
applied in different a Grigori instance
our Islands and their inflatable
barriers which in fact were they are
being used in the Netherlands and in
Japan the whole idea is that you don't
have to have a damn that you can have
and we rarely need these things but
sometimes we do need to prevent a storm
surge from destroying a vast residential
area so these are scalable ideas I think
I mean currently to take off on the the
work in New Orleans there is a very
large scale project now relative to the
re-engineering of the Lower Mississippi
River Delta where the the flows of the
the Mississippi in the way it kind of
relates to the the territory around New
Orleans is being restructured at a kind
of kind of radical broad scale as part
of a major kind of government initiative
as part about one of the things that's
being sort of examined is the kind of
role of the wetlands which because of
the channelization of the river for
shipping have been kind of gradually
kind of depleted over the course of the
last hundred years or so and have been
really seen as one of the major sources
for the the kind of kind of devastating
impact of Katrina and those in those
territories which is that this kind of
pre-existing porous edge which which had
kind of acted as a zone of deterrence
for storm surge had been
kind of decimated Guillen or dancin
actually who did the latrobe study at
the kind of impetus of the rising
currents project is actually looking at
that context I think the hope is that
some of these ideas will begin to kind
of infiltrate and kind of through
disseminate I mean I think they're there
was a recent discussion with some of the
city agencies where you know the kind of
reality that it's very unlikely that
without some major kind of catastrophic
event or at least the kind of threat of
it that these kinds of massive
large-scale infrastructure projects are
going to be affected in the short term
in New York City i think one of the
hopes is is that when the water does
start to rise and some of these things
may I should become necessary in a more
kind of short-term way that these
solutions these studies in this research
will be out there to be kind of called
from to be taken advantage of and that
the thinking already may be somewhat
changed and in terms of the way people
might approach these but there are
incredible bureaucratic and and kind of
structural barriers to that and i think
that the hope is that this begins to
make inroads i would put a question back
to Reinhold and that was your your
premise on what the projects are and
this notion of you know they're never
going to get bill to do that like it's a
lot of crews why why is that I mean this
is I don't want to be critical but this
is like Mickey Mouse stuff I mean we've
all been doing this in graduate schools
for the last 15 years in my Studios and
all of our studios so I mean what is the
trope of this kind of thinking that we
that this is somehow like oh you know
it's a museum project I mean what what
is that saying I mean even this notion
of the the Mississippi which you know
has been on the board for for 20 years I
mean the second that the Mississippi
lovely river was levied there started to
be land subsidence at the rate of
football fields per day and literally
Louisiana
losing a huge percentage of his landline
but then the actual rerouting of the
Mississippi is some it's like night 23
mm I mean it's some kind of figure which
I'm like somebody write a check it's so
basic and and makes so you know why is
it that there is no ability to move in
ways that are other than aggregate
because I mean that's that's all so I'm
kind of falling back to the thesis of
the oyster textured project but there
seems to be a complete inability to
coordinate organize and fund big
construction projects with the exception
of bridges and roads and and you know
projects that are somehow subsidized by
by big industry so so the fact that that
the presumption is that these projects
would never get built kind of prison
fury eights me because I mean it just
doesn't make any sense as architects to
somehow accept that yeah no I mean I'm
certainly wouldn't want to imply some
sort of defeatist position is sort of
the opposite the reason for maybe you
know provoking on that score is is to
ask what constitutes the reality of the
work that we do it is very interesting
to hear the response even the questions
as people go to more important things
the questions that have to do with like
like technological I don't at least one
and probably there are more
technological issues I mean this would
be described in old language as
functionalism that the language that
we're speaking so functionalism is back
that's the other conclusion you can
arrive at and functionalism speaks about
you know kind of practical reality in
certain ways and including the
possibility of realizing one's ambitions
the other related concept would be a
kind of realism where the down-to-earth
pneus they even though it's in a moma
you know it's it's accessible first of
all to a larger than classic moment
audience because anyway moment has
has become a shopping mall basically and
we have to acknowledge that it's become
Venice but also that that's where the
real and where what that's what's real
what's real is policy or you know or
politics in in that sense in the sense
of like people writing the check and and
so on I totally agree I mean I'm not the
least bit disagreeing with that you know
kind of premise but but I think in order
to get at the question we have to ask
you know exactly what you asked why is
that and I don't think there's a
practical answer that question anything
there's an ideological answer to that
question the ideology and that's where
architecture operates architecture
operates at the discursive level it
changes people's minds it doesn't eat
whether it's built or not that's and
that's how I understood your point
actually about science and figure
because I mean I fair for us what is
pleasurable about this whole experience
is precisely the ambiguity between those
two conditions I mean I don't think we
ever stayed out to say this is how
you're going to solve the world but
there was a grain of course of honest
sincere thinking about that of course on
the other hand we wanted to make an art
project or something that's you know we
wanted to
to representation or whatever just like
understanding the context if this is
being in MoMA and not you know some
planning whatever publication so it's
clearly has its context of defining it
but I think at the same time we're all
sincerely trying to address the issues
that can actually in fact i think that's
that's what becomes quite interesting
here is that there's really a kind of
conflation of those movements and in
others that these things simply wear yet
another kind of dry planning study that
kind of solved in a kind of technocratic
away the necessity of this and it kind
of pure a functionalist way I don't
think they would have the head way or
the possible impact that they do if I
think as we also hope these things
became sort of their own accord
provocative documents provocative kind
of architectural explorations and
engaged a level of convention and sort
of productivity that that in a way is
appropriate to the context of the
a shin in a way but also I think desire
that we all had to not simply answer the
question but to do something else tried
to kind of transform that that initial
question to something that was also
satisfying to us as architects design
you
that's happening yeah i mean what's
there's this great quote by Daniel
Moynihan this herb eminent former
senator who you know he basically grew
up around Times Square he actually
didn't know that Manhattan was an island
because when he was growing up the the
waterfront was this really heavy
industry you know on the waterfront you
know the kind of classic Waterman kind
of you know no-go zone ill repute and of
course I mean that's directly i think
tied to the economic context and where I
think New York is making a mistake is
that New York is now kind of in this
process of wholesale transforming its
waterfront into you know we were one
hundred percent industrial and now we're
going to be a hundred percent
recreational and it's completely ill ill
informed because the way that New York
will actually reengage its waterfront I
mean okay so I have a project of battery
park city there's one boat tie up in
Battery Park City or something of you
know I mean that there's so it's it's
you know the land is reaching the water
but it's not necessarily this kind of
engagement I mean another kind of thing
that irks me is that you know the water
used to be I mean it still is in some
cases this kind of major kind of
infrastructure transporting waste salt
you know
barges of garbage but all of that has
now been eliminated from waterfront
usage so until New York can find some
kind of mean classic example is Brooklyn
Bridge Park which I wouldn't criticize
from a point of landscape there's trees
and rolling hills and you know but I
used to get wood there I used there used
to be a lumberyard there which you could
buy you know and and it you know it was
working peers so this kind of holds sale
transformation to you know high-end
residential and Gaslight park is very
ill-advised because it will not lead to
what you're talking about which is this
kind of reengagement not without
multiple industries smaller industries
scales of transport being able to to
reimagine and kind of a more regional
economy I mean you know we're talking
about like hun gene ships now the Panama
Canal was what widened because it wasn't
wide enough for the Hajim kind of
shipping operations so like what does
that mean for you know this is the
economy of scouting we have to like re
recalibrate some of those you know sort
of this global economy and be able to
reclaim a kind of regionalism I think
relative to the waterfront and a mix of
economic recreational living you know
fishing a real mix of kind of
productivity I mean there's huge missed
opportunities like going to suggest same
time the city planning you know
commissioned agency does actually say
that they want a multiple waterfront and
I mean we have some wonderful
presentations there is a kind of
emerging I think consensus that we made
mistakes I mean with all these condos
everywhere and parks but i agree with
cake we couldn't agree more and it's
because of New York is becoming less
important so we don't have a huge
shipping
no arguments almost one argument
yeah I mean Fresh Kills has an
interesting political history too
because it was the dump for for New York
I mean truck barges dumped all of the
five boroughs garbage in Staten Island
so the city came up with the idea to as
part of the sort of Giuliani shipped to
close to get the Staten Island
Republican vote to close the landfill
and give it as a park as a sort of a
gift to the residence so that sort of
core gesture of making this formerly you
know what was a wetland that then became
this amazing you know masses of dumps of
garbage and into into a park and that's
also happened all along the in Jamaica
Bay there are former landfills that have
been planted and so on and you know and
I I'm I would say that the issue that I
have there is that New York closed that
landfill without a plan for its garbage
and so we ended up trucking garbage and
putting our garbage on rails and where
it was transported as far as Idaho in
most cases to sort of Virginia Ohio so
for me I i am a you know yeah I wrote
articles about the competition and
loudoun it and but at the same time it
was in this possibly no lack of an a
larger discussion about the notion of
being a productive productivity really
and systems that really are urban
systems and I mean this comment was made
about Manhattan and that these these
projects are Manhattan being like this
inherently sustainable dense situation
and you know so one of the main issues
that we really have to deal with is
waste we're incredibly sustainable in
terms of party walls and heating and but
but you know we have not solved that
waste problem so I thought that that
Fresh Kills is an amazing achievement by
the city but at the same time it was it
was generated as a sort of a political
gesture without this
larger discussion about waste and and
you know at the same time there's this
many technologies like waste to energy
or the combustion of ways to create
electricity that were completely off the
table that are incredibly sustainable
and because of local issues so it was
sort of a amazing gesture but at the
same time lacking sums or larger context
you